Je cherche Mark tu dois être sa
femme de ménage non je suis sa femme est-ce une
sorte de strip-teaseuse ou quelque chose comme ça
Carly est une femme qui est très concentrée comme
quelqu'un sur le point de se faire baiser
tu me baises je te revisse je suis un  une femme comme ça
Cameron Diaz était définitivement un tirage au sort pour
moi car je n'avais jamais travaillé avec Cameron
avant Cameron qui joue Carlene elle n'est
pas l'avocate typique elle est un
peu plus une fille habillée celle-ci est une
subvention Martin en soie rouge avec Cameron nous
essayons de  restez classique mais ayez toujours un
petit avantage celui-ci est une
robe droite en crêpe avec un petit lamay doré
c'est le sac de travail de Carly valextra c'est
un sac à main mais nous le jouons comme une mallette
pour les chaussures Carly c'est un peu votre
talon haut classique c'est  propre un sexy
c'est une femme contemporaine réussie
et sophistiquée devrait se révéler
dans le style avez-vous des gros
jeans pour les semaines sanglantes vous savez ce
que j'avais des chaussures de course